The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So good afternoon.
Our main topic today
is to understand
light forces, in particular
the stimulated force using
the dressed atom picture.
And I hope once you understand
how light forces can
be described in the
dressed atom picture
you will love the
dressed atom picture,
as most atomic physicists do.
It is really the
language we use,
the intuition we apply
to atomic systems.
Whenever we have a laser
beam which drives the atom
it is, in most situations,
more appropriate
and better to use dressed
states as your basis states
and not the naked,
the bare states, which
are ground and excited state.
Now I know last
week I quickly went
though the dressed atom picture.
Let me sort of go
through it in a fly-over
by not doing any
of the derivation,
but making a few
comments here and there.
Also, because I want
that some of the results
are fresh in your
head when we apply it
to mechanical forces of light.
So I told you that in
the dressed atom picture
we have two kinds of
interactions, the atom
interact with a vacuum,
with a reservoir
of empty modes with
spontaneous emission.
And we also interact
with a laser field.
And the new feature about
the dressed atom picture
is that we first
solve this exactly,
we rediagonalize the Hamiltonian
for that Hilbert space,
and then we allow spontaneous
emission to happen.
Now the derivation is
pretty straightforward.
After a number of
assumptions, we simply
came to the two-by-two
matrix, where
we have two levels of the
atoms coupled with the Rabi
frequency.
I derived it here for you using
the quantized electromagnetic
field.
But in your homework you derive
the same two-by-two matrix
using a classical
electromagnetic field,
which drives the atoms.
And we've talked about the
similarities and differences
last week.
If you have any questions,
please raise your hand
or interrupt me.
Now two-by-two matrix
is fairly trivial.
We can immediately
diagonalize it.
And we find
Eigensolutions, which
are just sine theta,
cosine theta, amplitude,
linear superpositions
of the naked states.
And the naked states are ground
and excited states, state A
and state B, with N or N plus
1 photons in the laser field.
So it's simple.
It's just a two-by-two matrix.
But the insight we
can get out of it
is pretty profound
and pretty subtle.
So what we first
discussed is-- and we
will need that to
understand forces and energy
conservation-- we can now
look at spontaneous emission.
Spontaneous emission coupling
to the empty modes of the vacuum
can only connect an excited
state B with a ground state A.
And therefore, we
have diachromatically
those four combinations,
represented here
by those four arrows.
And if you look for
the matrix element,
you collect cosine theta
and sine theta factors.
And that's what we did here.
So we immediately get in
the dressed atom picture,
an expression
which tells us what
are the matrix elements for
the carrier, for the blue
and for the red detuned
sideband of the Mollow triplet.
But then there's
something else, and I
edit this with the
lecture notes in green.
We can also, now, if you know
what the transition rates are,
we can set up rate equations
and can solve them.
And once you solve a set of
differential equations for rate
equations, you know what
the populations are.
But now, today, I want to
tell you one more subtlety.
You know already
that you cannot,
in the most general situation,
formulate an equation with just
a population.
You know that we have
the master equation,
we have the Optical
Bloch Equation.
This is an equation
for the density matrix.
And usually we get equations
where the populations
are mixed with coherences.
In other words, you cannot just
say the diagonal matrix element
of the density matrix
is a population,
and the change of population
is what goes out of this state
and what arrives in this state.
Coherences play a role.
But, and this is what the
dressed atom picture does
for you, in the limit that we
have a strong Rabi frequency--
and this is the limit you
want to consider here--
the matrix equation
decouples into an equation
for populations and an
equation for coherences.
And if something decouples
that should tell you we
all on the right track, we
have the right description.
In this description things
decouple, things are simpler.
And that means
this description is
most appropriate for the
physics we want to understand.
Or, to say it more
specifically-- and all
the details of course
are in the book
Atom Photon Interaction-- you
can rewrite the Optical Bloch
Equations not in the bare bases
but in the dressed atom basis.
And in the dressed
atom basis you
find this wonderful
separation between populations
and coherences.
So we have the simple
rate equations.
By setting the
left hand side to 0
we find the steady
state populations.
This will be very important to
understand the light forces.
But you should just remember
the steady state solution such
as we know them.
They're just exactly given
by this angle theta, which
tells us what kind
of superposition
of the bare states from
the dressed states.
Remember in the case of
theta equals 45 degrees,
the dressed states are just
symmetric and antisymmetric
superposition of
the naked states.
Now what is also important
is those rate equations,
or those rate equations
have a time constant.
The time constant is
here, the relaxation time
for populations.
And we know exactly what it is.
It's a little bit more
complicated to find
the equivalent equation
for the coherences.
But just take my word,
the density matrix
in the dressed atom basis
decouples into equation
for population, which is
simple, equation for coherences,
little bit harder to
derive but looks the same.
And from this equation we have
now an expression for what
is the relaxation
time for coherences.
And just to show you
one non-trivial example,
if you add up cosine square
plus sine square you get 1.
But based on what
we derived we have
to take cosine to the power
of 4, sine to the power of 4.
And this gives us effect of
1/2, which will appear somewhere
in an important place
in a few minutes.
So with that we can now
address, we know now something
about the intensities
of this Mollow triplet,
because the intensity is nothing
else than the population,
what is the population in
the initial state times
the matrix element squared.
But what is also-- what
comes out very naturally--
is that we have
different widths.
The features have
The sidebands have
a different width
from the central part
of the Mollow triplet.
And well, this is now
very naturally interpreted
at one has a width,
which is a relaxation
rate for the population.
The other one, is the
sidebands have a width
which is a relaxation
rate for the coherences.
I showed you, and this was just
a reminder of a few weeks ago,
that when we looked at the
linear matrix equation, which
are the Optical
Bloch Equation, we
discussed complex
eigenvalues mathematically.
And those complex eigenvalues,
the imaginary part
is the sideband frequency.
And the real part
was the widths.
What I have now, sort
of-- I can get everything
from the dressed atom picture.
But what I've gotten in a
very natural and simple way
is this case, which is the
case where the dressed atom
picture is particularly simple.
It's called the
secular case, where
the population and
coherences decouple.
And so, what I just showed you,
that the population relaxation
time is gamma over 2.
This explains now
why, in this case,
the widths of the
central feature
is 1/2 of what it is
when we're on resonance.
So everything is sort of
nicely playing out here.
OK, any questions about
dressed level populations,
rate equations,
the Mollow triplet?
Because we want to apply
it now, in a few minutes,
to the stimulated light force.
But before I do
that, let me show you
one nice piece of physics,
which can be formulated
both in the bare,
in the uncoupled,
and in the dressed state basis.
And this is the process
of spontaneous emission.
If an atom is in
the laser field,
it just emits photon,
rapid fire photons.
And I want to show you now,
how we would describe it
in the bare basis,
how we describe it
in the dressed basis.
And we get two very different
physical pictures out of it.
Well, in the bare
basis, maybe just
think of quantum Monte
Carlo simulation,
a photon has been
emitted, and that
means we are in
the ground state.
Now it takes a Rabi cycle
before the ground state
atom is in the excited state.
And when it is in the excited
state, it can emit again
and goes back to
the ground state.
And then things start over.
So the picture you obtain here
is the picture of antibunching,
that the atom emits
a photon, but then it
takes the inverse Rabi
frequency to load the gun again.
And then it can fire again
and emit the next photon.
So therefore, the probability
of getting another photon right
after you've observed the
first photon is reduced,
or T equals 0, it is exactly 0.
And this is antibunching,
the photons are antibunched.
So this is how we would describe
the radiative cascade, how
we go from N to N minus 1, to
N minus 2, how we lose photons
from the laser
field and dump them
into the empty
modes of the vacuum.
That's how we describe it
in the uncoupled basis.
Well in the dressed
basis we have sort of
diagonalized the
atoms interacting
with the strong laser field.
And now we would have
the following picture.
We have this manifold here.
We can emit from this manifold.
And we can go to the upper
or lower dressed state.
And then, the next
thing will happen again.
But what we realize here, if we
are in the upper dressed state,
we can either emit
on the carrier
or we can emit a
blue detune sideband.
But once we have emitted
a blue detune sideband,
the next sideband has to be
red detuned because we are now
in the lower dressed state,
and we need a lower sideband
to go back to the
upper dressed state.
So what this picture gives
us, it gives us the sidebands
because we are resolving the
splitting in this picture.
And secondly, it
tells us that there
is an alternation between
the blue detuned photons
and the red detuned photon.
Now you would say, well
aren't those two pictures
really different?
In one case we
have antibunching,
and all of the
photons are the same.
And over here I talk
about an alternation
between the blue and
the red sideband.
Well again, the two
pictures are complementary.
In this case, if I want to
resolve the antibunching
I need a temporal
resolution which
is better than the
inverse Rabi frequency.
But if my temporal resolution
is better than the inverse Rabi
frequency then I don't have
the spectral resolution
to observe the sidebands,
and vice versa.
If I want to resolve
the sidebands,
if I want to distinguish the red
from the blue detuned sideband
of the Mollow triplet I
cannot run the experiment with
the spectral resolution, which
would be required to observe
the antibunching.
So these are sort of
two different pictures.
One is sort of in terms
of energy eigenstates
when we have
spectral resolution.
And this other picture
is more appropriate
when we're interested in
the short time domain.
So in that sense, you need both.
You need the bare basis.
You need to dressed basis.
And you have to just know for
which physical process, which
of them allows the more
direct description.
Questions?
OK, so this was partly
review, partly preparation
for the next big
chapter, namely we
want to understand the dipole
forces within the dressed atom
picture.
The book Atom Photon Interaction
has a nice summary of it.
But the more detailed picture,
and I heavily draw from this,
is in the truly seminal article
by Jean Dalibard and Claude
Cohen-Tannoudji.
I've linked this
article to our website.
So I've summarized here pretty
much what I just told you.
This is sort of the summary
from the previous section.
What we have to know is
to understand light forces
in the dressed atom
picture is number one,
the energy speaking
between the two.
The splitting between the two is
the generalized Rabi frequency.
If there's anything
which is not--
well I shouldn't say 100%--
but at least 90% clear to you,
ask me question.
I mean these are the
results we really
need for the
following discussion.
So number one is
the dressed energy
levels are split by the
generalized Rabi frequency.
Number two is with
this angle theta, which
came from the solution
of diagonalizing
the two-by-two matrix, we
have now the steady state
populations in the upper and
in the lower dressed state.
And the third thing is when
we have a population when
we are not in steady state, then
the steady state populations
are obtained with the time
constant, which is given here.
The time constant
is not just gamma,
it's gamma times these
trigonometric functions.
So these are simple ingredients.
But by using those
ingredients we
can get a very nice formulation
for the stimulated force.
So what I've shown
here is, and this
is the situation we want
to focus on for a while.
Assume you focus a laser beam.
Then plot it as a
function of position.
The atom is outside
the laser beam,
it goes into the
laser beam where
it experiences the
electromagnetic field.
And if it goes further it
has crossed the laser beam
and is out of the
laser beam again.
So what happens is the splitting
between the two dressed
energy levels is the
generalized Rabi frequency.
And this is outside the laser
beam, simply the detuning.
But then when the
laser beam is on,
the generalized Rabi
frequency gets larger.
We have a larger lar splitting
between the dressed energy
levels, and so on.
What is also important
is that if the laser is
red detuned, which is here, the
lower dressed level correlates,
corresponds to the ground state.
Whereas for blue detuning the
ground state in this limit,
the ground state correlates
with the upper dressed level.
So it's important.
So therefore an atom in this
situation-- because atoms
are always more in
the ground state
than in the excited
state-- an atom
will have more population
in the upper dressed level.
And here it will have more
population the lower dressed
level.
So what we want to
do now is we want
to rewrite the stimulated light
force, or the dipole force,
as we want to express it
through the forces acting
on the dressed atom level.
Well, I told you that we have a
splitting of the dressed energy
levels by the generalized
Rabi frequency.
So therefore, if
I just cover that,
the energy level
of the two dressed
levels is h bar over 2 plus
minus the generalized Rabi
frequency.
And the force if an atom is
in one of the dressed levels
is simply the gradient of that.
So therefore we have the picture
that the two dressed energy
levels, atoms in those
two dressed levels,
always experience
opposite forces.
Then an expression
for the net force
is that the average
dipole force is
the force in dressed
level one times
the probability that the
atom is in dressed level one.
And the same for two.
And if you sum it up we
get exactly the expression
we have derived earlier for
the stimulated light force.
But let's just sort of look at
it in the following picture.
If we are blue detuned,
and let's assume
we are not saturating
the transition,
so therefore the atom will be
mainly in the ground state.
So you have more
population in that state.
But, well, if the
laser power is 0,
we have 100% population here.
But when the atom moves
into the laser beam
there is a superposition of
ground and excited state.
But that also means
there's a superposition
of upper and lower
dressed level.
But we have always, of
course, more population
in the dressed level which
connects to the ground state
because an atom will-- well, it
also comes out of the solution.
But it's natural, just assume
you make the laser beam weak,
you start in the ground
state and everything
is sort of connected.
The ground state
is simply dressed
by a small excited
state contribution.
So that explains it, why
for blue detuned light,
the physics is mainly in
the upper dressed level.
And we see the repulsive dipole
force of a blue detuned laser.
Whereas, for red detuned
light, the dominant population
is in the lower
dressed level, and we
have an attractive force.
Well that's simple.
We haven't gained so
much, but you'll see,
we can now rapidly gain insight
by take it to the next level.
Let me first mention
a trivial example.
And this is when we
are on resonance.
When we are on resonance we
have equal population in the two
dressed states, they
are resonantly mixed.
And therefore if the
population in the two
dressed states is the same,
but the atoms experience
opposite forces, that means the
dipole force average out to 0.
In a few minutes I want
to calculate for you
what the heating is.
The dipole force is 0.
But you know the atom in
this radiative cascade
is making transitions between
upper and lower dressed level.
So what does it
mean for the atom?
When it is in one dressed
level it experience the force
from this side.
If the atom is in the
other dressed level,
it's experience a
force from that side.
So the atom is actually subject
to an average force which is 0.
But if you take these picture
literally, and you can,
the atom is really whacked
left, right, left, right, left,
right.
And there is fluctuations.
And we can use those fluctuating
forces to immediately calculate
what is the heating.
The force average is 0, but
the fluctuations of the force
cause heating.
So that's immediately the
next step of physical insight
we will get out of this picture.
But before I do that I
want to do something else.
I want to discuss
what happens now
to the force when the
atom is slowly moving.
Remember, there is
still one phenomenon
which I owe you an
explanation for.
And this is when we
discussed molasses.
We always had the effect
in optical molasses
with a spontaneous
light force that we
need red detuning of the
laser beam to get cooling.
The simple picture is the atom
absorbs a red detuned photon
and emits away a
resonant photon.
And then that energy
difference is taken away
from the kinetic energy,
and this is cooling.
But then I told
you that when you
go to higher power
of the standing wave,
the sine of alpha of the
friction coefficient reverses.
And that means cooling is now
done by blue detuned light,
heating is done by
red detuned light.
And that's what we
want to understand.
So in order to get any cooling
effect, or heating effect,
we have to now
change the equation
we had for the
average dipole force.
Remember also, the
average dipole force,
we did that earlier, can be
derived from a potential.
It's a gradient over potential.
So therefore, when you
fly through a laser beam
you go down and up or up
and down the potential,
but nothing has happened to you.
But the assumption
we had for that
is that the dipole force was
calculated with a steady state
population.
So now we want to say
if the atom is slowly
moving it may not
be fully adiabatic,
and we want to calculate
the first correction
to the non-adiabaticity.
So in other words, we have
the following picture.
When an atom flies
through the laser beam
it needs a certain time
to adjust its population.
And the question,
what is this time?
Well, it is the relaxation
time for the populations
among the dressed
states to adjust.
And this is exactly the
inverse of the rate gamma
pop, which we have
calculated earlier.
So the physical picture now
is that in the dressed level
one and two, the population
at any given moment
is almost the steady state.
But there is a time
lag, a time lag
by the time it takes to relax.
So in other words, the
atom is always a little bit
behind in adjusting
to the laser field
because it takes a
finite amount of time.
So let's now try to understand,
in this picture which
we have obtained
with a laser beam
the two dressed levels and
the atom flying through,
let's try to understand what
this extra lag time means.
So the atom is flying
into the laser beam.
It starts out in
the ground state,
which means 100% in the
upper dressed energy level.
Now, in the laser beam the
higher the laser power is,
the more there is a mixture of
the other dressed energy level.
But what happens is,
when the atom is here,
when it just assume it flies in,
and there was not enough time
to adjust the
population, that would
mean that the atom-- and this
is indicated with the red dots--
that the atom has a
little bit of more
population in the
upper dressed level
than it would have
in equilibrium
But what does it
mean for the force
now, if there is more
population here than there?
Well, the more population
you have in the upper state,
the more you're
climbing up a hill,
the more you get a
force to the left.
So this red arrow shows due
to the non-adiabaticity,
due to the time lag, there
is a little extra force
to the left hand side.
So this is on the up hill.
Let's now understand what
happens on the down hill.
Well, we just have to
keep track of signs.
Here, the atom, in a
fairly high laser field,
is in the upper dressed level
with a mixture in the lower
dressed level.
But now it flies out
of the laser beam,
but it cannot immediately
adjust its population.
And that means it
wants to have now
more population in the
upper dressed level
but it hasn't fully adjusted.
So therefore, instead of
having the blue bullet, which
represents equilibrium, the
atom has the red bullet.
It has a little bit
lower population in that,
and higher population there.
But lower population here
and hire population here
means-- if you have a little
bit higher population than you
should have here it means
you are climbing up the hill,
and there is an extra force,
which is again, to the left.
So we realize the
n the time lag,
means when an atom goes up
the hill there's a little bit
extra force to the left.
And when it goes
down the hill there
is a little bit extra
force to the left.
And after it has flown
through the steady state
part of the force roller
coaster up down, which
can be derived from a
potential, has integrated to 0.
But what is left is this
non-adiabatic component
of the force which is
slowing down the atom.
In other words, I have shown
you in this simple picture
that the time lag in adjusting
the dressed energy population
means that there is a small
differential force which
is slowing down the atom.
And what I assumed
here was blue detuning.
So we have cooling, we have
friction for blue detuned light
when it comes to the
stimulated force.
Now this picture, this
equation that the population is
a steady state at the
given position minus a time
lag, we can solve it.
And I'm not doing
it here because it
involves a few
mathematical equations.
But by just using these answers,
and the rest is straight
forward, you can then
arrive at an expression
for the stimulated
for the dipole force.
Colin?
AUDIENCE: So, in the
spirit of last time,
keeping track of the
energy, the energy here
would be going into
the fact that now I
have-- if the atom's
a harmonic oscillator
it's a little behind
the drive field?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you imprint some
fluctuation on the laser beam,
and that's where the
energy's being carried off,
in the laser beam?
PROFESSOR: Well the energy's
carried off by the laser beam.
I have actually
prepared something
which I want to
show you in 10 or 15
minutes, where the energy goes.
So let's maybe do
that in a moment.
So this is a physical picture.
And I think what is also
important I want to later tell
you, for other laser
cooling mechanisms, which
are too complicated to describe,
but they also have a time lag.
And I think, I try to
teach you basic concepts
by using this simplest
physical picture I can have.
And what can be simpler than two
levels of an atom and one laser
beam?
But what you understand here
with this stimulated force,
which is also called
blue molasses,
is for the first
time how a time lag
in adjusting to the
local laser field,
how that leads to cooling.
I'm summarizing
here, simply taking
this picture, this
equation, and you
know, turning the crank on it.
The paper by Jean Dalibard
and Claude Cohen-Tannoudji
calculates what is the
dipole force in steady state.
We get almost the same
result with the Optical Bloch
Equations, but we
are discussing here
the limit that the Rabi
frequency is larger than gamma.
So therefore, if you're
missing occurrences of gamma,
they don't appear here
because we've always
assumed omega is larger
than gamma in this picture.
Now I want to apply
this picture now,
not just going through one
hump of the laser field,
but going through
a standing wave.
So we have a standing wave of
light, which is blue detuned.
Of course, in a
standing wave of light,
if you ever reach over
one optical wavelengths,
you go up the hill,
you go down the hill,
the lambda average
dipole force is 0.
But now you find that if
you put in this time lag,
you find a friction force, with
a friction coefficient alpha.
And this friction coefficient is
cooling for blue detuned light.
Now I don't want to
elaborate on this expression.
But if you take the treatment
of Jean Dalibard and Claude
Cohen-Tonnoudji, which
is very transparent.
It reads wonderfully easily,
as the book Atom Photon
Interaction.
In the limit of large
detuning, which is the simplest
possibly limit, you find
the friction coefficient
which looks highly nontrivial.
It depends to the sixth power
of the Rabi frequency and such.
The only reason why I put
it here, in 20 minutes
I want to give you a very,
very simple picture where
I derive that for you.
So that's just a check mark.
Any questions right
now about-- because I
want to go on-- about
the stimulated force
in the dressed atom picture?
And if we allowed deviations
from the steady state
population we get
a cooling effect,
and this explains the
effect of blue molasses.
And we've applied it
to a standing wave.
Cody?
AUDIENCE: Just [INAUDIBLE]
the upper alpha
are a friction constant
and the lower one
is the polarizability?
Or, something.
PROFESSOR: No, oh,
thanks for asking.
Alpha, yeah, we [INAUDIBLE].
Here it's the
friction coefficient.
Here, remember when we
had the light force--
the spontaneous light force and
the stimulated light force--
one was directed
along a vector alpha,
and the other one
along a vector beta.
Alpha was pointing
into the direction
of the gradient of
the laser intensity,
and beta was the phase
gradient of the laser beam.
So those two have
nothing to do--
this is friction coefficient.
This is the direction for
the stimulated light force.
And yes, a little
bit later today,
I will use alpha again,
but for the polarizability.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The [INAUDIBLE]
track the atoms
in the [INAUDIBLE]
standing wave, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You're talking
about trap in here,
that if you have a standing
wave of blue detuned light--
well if the standing wave
is infinitely extended then
the atom is always
in the standing wave.
But if you use two Gaussian
laser beams to form a standing
wave, there is
always a net force
to expel the atoms away
from blue detuned light,
because blue detuned light
has an average dipole
force which is repulsive.
So whenever you want
to manipulate atoms
with blue detuned light you need
an additional magnetic trap,
or an additional red
detuned optical trap.
Because whatever you want to
do with atoms, if you want
to do it with atoms
in steady state
you have to keep
the atoms together.
And what keeps
the atoms together
is red detuned optical
traps, or magnetic traps.
The blue detuned
light can be used
to create a blue
detuned lattice.
Or it can be used
at least, if you
want to do laser cooling with
blue detuned light it can
be used for laser
cooling, as I've
started to describe for you now.
But yes, I mean, in that
sense as an experimentalist,
you can run experiments where
you have only red detuned
light-- red detuned
light for trapping,
red detuned light for cooling.
But if you use blue detuned
light for a standing wave
or for blue
molasses, in addition
you will always use
red detuned light
to keep the clouds together.
So pretty much every
experiment usually
has some red detuned
light for confinement.
And you have to then
match blue detuned light
with red detuned light to
get the two things you want.
We can now use the
dressed atom picture
to calculate the heating.
Remember the final
temperature you can reach
was always the ratio between
a heating coefficient, which
is actually the momentum
diffusion coefficient,
over alpha.
So right now we have
understood the alpha part.
We know the physical
picture, why alpha
provides cooling, why
we have a friction
force for blue detuned light.
But let's now take
it to the next step,
and calculate what
is the heating.
And I mentioned it already in
the context of simple molasses,
which we discussed, I
think, two weeks ago,
that we describe heating by the
momentum diffusion coefficient.
Well the momentum
diffusion coefficient
tells you that P
square is simply
growing as a function of time.
If you have a cold cloud
and you heat it up,
you can describe the heating
by the temporal growth
of P square.
If you don't like
momentum, divide P
squared by 2m you have
the kinetic energy, which
increases.
So it is this momentum
diffusion coefficient.
And if you have a cloud which
moves with an average momentum,
you only want to have the P
square minus P average square.
But if you think about a
cloud which is being cooled,
the second term is 0.
So the momentum
diffusion coefficient
is the derivative of P square.
But the derivative of
P is simply the force.
So therefore we can absorb the
derivative by replacing P--
at least one of the
P's-- by the force.
And we can now get
rid of to second P
of the second
occurrence of momentum
by saying well momentum
is derivative of force.
Sorry, derivative of
momentum is force,
or momentum is the
integral of force.
So we can exactly rewrite that
momentum diffusion coefficient
by an integral over
correlation function of forces.
And then we have the
nice physical picture
that with increase
of kinetic energy,
the momentum
diffusion coefficient
comes because we have
fluctuations of the force.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: With the last
time, the previous page
the factor [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The factor of 2 here?
AUDIENCE: No, the next slide.
PROFESSOR: Here is 2.
AUDIENCE: For both terms.
And here it disappears,
because we have a factor of 2
and a factor of 2, and
the two cancel each other.
AUDIENCE: No, I meant, there's a
2 multiplied the first average.
And there's a 2
for the second one.
Are those for the first term?
PROFESSOR: I think
this is correct.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What happens
is P-- you use--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: No, it's
supposed to be--
PROFESSOR: Wait, is one missing?
Maybe [INAUDIBLE].
I think you're right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Let's assume
this is what it should be.
So here is the reminder,
the kinetic energy.
If you have a process which
causes momentum diffusion,
the momentum
diffusion coefficient
gives you the heating rate.
And the cooling rate is given by
our friction coefficient alpha.
And as we discussed in
the context of molasses--
of red detuned molasses, but it
applies to any cooling scheme--
the finite temperature
is when you
have detail balance
between heating and cooling
And therefore its ratio
of the momentum diffusion
coefficient over the
friction coefficient.
Kensie?
AUDIENCE: In the
previous step, what
was the significance of
choosing f of 0 basically?
Like, the time arguments were
0 and D. So we said that f of 0
was DPDT?
PROFESSOR: Oh, we assumed that
the laser beam's Hamiltonian is
invariant against
time translation,
and we simply evaluate
that at T equals 0.
I mean, that's of the argument
you have fluctuating forces.
And you could have
fluctuating forces
at time T and time T prime.
But then you use the augment
that in a steady state solution
the correlation
function does not
depend on T and T prime
separately, but only
on the difference.
And then you simply
set one argument to 0,
and the other argument
becomes a time difference.
Other questions?
So now, by understanding
that momentum diffusion is
nothing else than the integral
over the force fluctuation,
we can now use this physical
picture which I gave you
earlier that an
atom which cascades
through upper, lower,
upper, lower dressed states
will experience opposite but
equal forces, form the right
and from the left.
So I can simply evaluate that
by assuming we are on resonance.
On resonance the force is h
bar over 2 times the derivative
of the generalized
Rabi frequency.
And the force
correlation, what is it?
Well, it's the force
f of 0 times f of T.
But as long as the atom
is in one dressed state
the force doesn't change.
So I simply take here the
force, I take the force squared,
and then when I integrate over
that, well the moment the atom
makes a transition
there is no longer
any correlation
between the force.
Everything becomes random and
the integral averages out to 0.
So in other words,
that's the way
how you should look
at this integral.
You start with the
force f0, as long
as the force is correlated.
Because the atom hasn't
done spontaneous emission,
you have sort of f of 0, f of 0.
And you integrate it,
nominally to infinity.
But you simply integrate it
until some spontaneous emission
randomizes the system.
So therefore, this integral
over the correlation function
is nothing else then the force
squared times the typical time
scale for a transition.
So if you put that
in on resonance,
we have the force here,
we square the force.
And then we multiply with the
spontaneous emission rate,
which for resonance
system is gamma over 2.
And with that we get now
the heating coefficient,
the momentum
diffusion coefficient
for an atom which is
exposed to resonant light
due to the stimulated
light force.
The paper, the references
I've given you,
is simply taking this
augment and extending that
to arbitrary detuning.
For arbitrary detuning, I told
you what happens on resonance.
The atom spends equal amount
in each dressed state.
If you detune the atom spends
more time in one dressed state,
then quickly in the
other dressed state,
and then more time in the
other dressed state again.
So you can, by
simply understanding
what are the rates for cascading
between the dressed levels,
you could pretty much write
down the expression, find it,
and here is the solution
taken out of the paper.
So we have to correct
prefactor, but then
if the detuning is
non-vanishing we
get a contribution
from the second factor.
Colin?
AUDIENCE: Are you assuming
the exponential correlation--
exponential behavior
to the correlation.
Because then you might
have different prefactors,
if it were something like if
you were in a [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well what
happens is the following.
I think if you're
in one dressed state
and the force pushes
you in one direction
and you integrate over it you
have an exponential decay.
But instead of integrating
over the exponential decay
you can just take
the force squared
and multiply it with the
average time the atom stays.
In other words, if I have an
exponentially decaying function
I can always approximate it
by the function of T equals
0 times the time.
And what you are
asking me now is
is the time the one over E
time, or is it an average time?
What is the correct
time to use here?
AUDIENCE: I guess when
the time scale depends
on how the correlations decay
for [INAUDIBLE] different.
PROFESSOR: Yes, OK, I agree.
The shape of the decay of
the correlation function
would matter.
I'm not going into that.
But what I'm sort
of assuming here
is that the correlation
function indicated with time
is the correlation function of
T equals 0 times the correlation
time.
And how the correlation
time is related
to the exponential
time, or if there's
a small prefactor and such,
that may depend on details.
Yes, you're right.
I've swept this under the rug.
How are we doing?
Good.
Let me just summarize.
The dressed atom
picture has given us
two pieces of major insight
into the stimulated force.
The first one is that the
atom experience is always
opposite forces in the
two dressed levels.
And it is the
population imbalance
between the two dressed levels
which results in a net force.
And this requires
either red detuning,
then the force is
repulsive, or blue
detuning-- sorry,
red detuning then
the force is attractive,
or blue detuning then it's
a force repulsive.
Second, with this
time lag thing,
we understand that time
lag, non-adiabaticity,
is the way to get cooling.
And the third thing we have
learned, when the atom does
a radiative cascade the force--
when it goes from the upper
to the lower dressed
level-- the force
is suddenly reversing it's sign.
And this causes fluctuations,
this shakes up atom,
and this causes heating.
And this has nothing to do with
the other heating mechanism we
discussed earlier,
namely every time there
is spontaneous emission
there's a random recoil.
In strong laser fields
the fluctuations
of the stimulated
force, which has
nothing to do with
spontaneous emission,
are much, much larger
than the photon recoil.
So therefore for
strong laser fields,
it is this alternation
of the force when
atoms switch dressed
energy levels, which
is responsible for
most of the heating.
I want to come now to another
physical situation, which
is actually wonderful.
You learn about
Sisyphus cooling.
Everybody in cold atoms
speaks about Sisyphus
cooling because it's a very,
very elegant cooling scheme.
We usually apply in the
laboratory Sisyphus cooling
when we do polarization
gradient cooling.
I will say you a
few things later.
But this is much, much harder
to understand than the Sisyphus
cooling, which takes place
for a two level atom moving
through a blue
detuned standing wave.
So in other words,
I try to explain now
to you what Sisyphus cooling is.
The relevant application
is multi-level polarization
gradient cooling, which
I give you an idea,
but it's hard to fully describe.
But here, in our current
discussion on the two level
atom interacting with one laser
beam, or one standing wave,
we find the simplest
physical realization
of Sisyphus cooling.
So just to make sure that you
are following the argument,
I have so far explained to you
why blue detuned light cools
in the limit of very
small velocities.
Very small velocity means
we did a first order Taylor
expansion in this lag time.
But now I want to discuss with
you a different regime, namely
that the atom moves
with a velocity such
that it can go up and down
several periods of the standing
wave before it does
spontaneous emission.
So before when we discussed
the friction coefficient,
the velocity was infinitesimal.
But now I assume that
the velocity is such
that the atom can
surf a few waves
and then it will
spontaneously emit.
And let me assume that
we are blue detuned.
So the atom, let's say here,
where the splitting is minimum,
well this is where
we don't have light.
The generalized Rabi frequency
is just the detuning.
So we are in a node
of the standing wave.
And then the atom starts
in the ground state,
and it experiences
the periodic potential
due to the standing wave.
But we want to now ask, OK,
when will spontaneous emission
happen in this picture?
Well, it cannot happen here,
when the atom is in the ground
state, when there is not light.
But where there is light, when
the atoms move to an anti-node,
there is a mixture, indicated
in red, of the excited state.
So in other words, when an
atom does this roller coaster,
it will most likely emit a
photon-- either the carrier
or one of the
sidebands-- when it
is at the maximum of the
potential corresponding
to an anti-node where it
experiences the light.
OK, when the atom
emits on the carrier
it goes from the
upper dressed level
to the upper dressed level.
Then sort of
nothing has happened
because the atom is in
the same dressed level.
Let me now discuss the case
when something happens.
And this is when the atom decays
from the upper dressed level
to the lower dressed level.
And at least for weak excitation
the lower dressed level
corresponds to
the excited state.
In other words, when
there is no light,
the upper dressed
level was ground state,
the lower dressed
level is excited state.
But what happens now is
actually interesting,
the atom had to
climb up the hill.
But the spontaneous emission
to the lower dressed level
takes the atom to the bottom.
So you can see, on average,
it has climbed a hill here,
but now it is at the bottom.
And now we're going to ask
how does the atom get out
of the lower dressed level?
Well, the lower
dressed level is mainly
excited-- is 100% excited
if there is no light.
But if there is light, and
light means the generalized Rabi
frequency is larger, the
excited state has now in it
mixture of the ground
state because the light
mixes ground and excited state.
So now, of course,
whenever there is red
you can spontaneously emit.
But there is a
probability that the atom
is more likely to emit when you
are in a purely excited state,
and not in a mixed state.
So now, talking about
the lower manifold,
the atom does it's
roller coaster.
It has a velocity
that it can cover
several periods of the
standing wave in one lifetime.
But there is a higher
probability for the atom
now to emit when it
is on top of the hill.
So that's remarkable.
We have the upper dressed level.
We have the lower dressed level.
The atom is doing
the roller coaster.
But whenever it emits a
sideband, whenever it switches
state, it mainly
does it by emitting
at the top of the hill.
And after the
spontaneous emission
it finds itself at the
bottom of the hill.
So on average the atom
is climbing more up hills
than down hills.
And this is called
Sisyphus cooling.
I think you've all heard
about the Greek myth of King
Sisyphus, who was condemned.
He challenged the gods
and he got his punishment.
And his punishment
was that he always
has to roll a stone up the hill.
And when he's done
the stone falls down
and he has to roll the stone up.
So in other words, we
have condemned the atoms
to the same verdict.
They always have to
go up hill to work.
Then they fall down
hill with the help
of a spontaneous photon.
But then they have
to climb up hill.
And it is the uphill climb where
the experience and net friction
force, which cools the
atoms down and reduces
their kinetic energy.
So this is Sisyphus cooling.
And since I need it
in a few minutes,
I just wrote down for you, based
on this simple and wonderfully
elegant picture,
how much energy does
the atom lose per unit time?
What is the cooling rate?
Well it's clear that
the cooling rate
comes when the atom switches
from one dressed energy
level to the next, because
nothing happens on the carrier.
So it is the transition state
between dressed level one
and dressed level two.
And then we multiply
with mu naught
the depths of the optical
lattice, because it
is this energy difference which
is extracted from the atom.
You may ask, OK what
is time limiting?
It's really the transition rate
form the first dressed level,
which is mainly ground state, to
the other dressed level, which
is mainly exciting state.
Because once the atom is in
this level, which is mainly
the excited state,
it will pretty much
do the next transition
at a rate which
corresponds to the
spontaneous emission rate.
So in other words, if you're
not fully on resonance,
or if you're not
situated in laser power,
the rate, one, two, is slower
than the rate two, one.
And therefore this rate
is the rate limiting step.
Let me show you
just a few pictures.
What I'm just explaining to
you was explored very early on,
just have to sort of put you
back that it was in the mid
'80s, '82, '83, '84, that people
developed [INAUDIBLE] slowing.
It was in '85 that optical
molasses with red detuned light
was demonstrated
for the first time.
It was in '86 that
the dipole trap
was demonstrated by Steve Chu.
And in '87 that Steve
Chu and Dave Pritchard
introduced the
magneto optic trap.
So the mid to late '80s
were fantastic times,
where one important technique
was realized and demonstrated.
And this was actually the
first major experimental paper
of a new laser
cooling group, which
was founded by Claude
Cohen-Tonnoudji at the Ecole
Normale Superieure in Paris.
And it was exactly about cooling
atoms with stimulated emission,
and this is blue molasses.
And, I mean, you exactly
see here out of this paper,
the Sisyphus cooling mechanism.
And addressing the question
about red detuned light here,
this was actually
beam experiment.
You head a blue
detuned standing wave,
and you were sending
an atomic beam through.
And if this atomic
beam was cooled,
the divergence of the
atomic beam was reduced.
So this experiment had only
one blue detuned standing wave
and nothing else, because it
was not a trapping experiment.
It was a beam
collimation experiment.
And what is shown
here is that you
have the original
atomic beam profile.
And for blue detuned light
you make it narrower,
so this is cooling.
Whereas for red detuned
light you have a defocusing,
which corresponds to heating.
Any question?
I want to wrap up the discussion
of the stimulated light force
by discussing pretty
much everything again,
but in the simplest
possibly limit.
That's actually
something I haven't
found in any text books.
But when I derived
it for myself it
helped me to really
understand it.
It's sort of the perturbative
result of the dressed atom
picture.
So everything is simple.
And by telling
you, look at this.
You know this is
just EC stock shift.
But in the dressed
atom picture it's
a generalized Rabi
frequency, you suddenly
understand the trivial
perturbative result
and how it translates into
the dressed atom picture.
So what I'm presenting you
now in the next 10 minutes,
it provides a lot of
insight because it
connects simple pictures.
So I'm discussing
things here in the limit
that the detuning is large.
The detuning is larger
than the Rabi frequency,
and spontaneous emission
rate is the smallest
of the three rates.
In that case, I can simply
do perturbation theory,
and I want to show you.
Also, because this
is pedagogical,
I just want to show you how
the effects come together.
I neglect all factors
on the order of unity.
And I set h bar to 1.
So let's assume we
have a standing wave.
A standing wave is cosine KX.
So we have an electric field.
But we describe the electric
field with a Rabi frequency.
So the Rabi frequency
forms a standing wave.
Now what are the
two dressed states?
The dressed states 1 and
2 are the bare states,
ground and excited state.
And then there a
perturbative mixture.
And in first order
perturbation theory
we take the matrix
element over the detuning.
So one dressed
state is the ground
state with a little bit
of excited stated mixed.
The other dressed state is
the excited state, minus sign,
little bit of ground stated mix.
These are our two dressed
states in the trivial limit
that we can apply
perturbation theory.
What are now the
transition rates
between the two dressed states?
Well, we want to make
spontaneous emission
from dressed state 1
to dressed state 2.
We have to go from this small
mixture, which is the excited
stated mixture, to
the ground state here.
So therefore we get the
product of the two amplitudes,
and then we multiply with gamma.
Of course, most of-- yeah.
So this is the rate to
go from dressed state
1 to dressed state 2.
What is the inverse rate to
go back from dressed state
2 to dressed state 1?
Well, you go from the excited
state to the ground state,
multiply with gamma,
and that's what you get.
Sure we have, in perturbation
theory, the coefficient is 1.
It's only in higher
order perturbation theory
that the coefficient of the
bare state becomes less than 1.
So isn't that simple?
We just discussed it with
all the cosine to the 4,
sine to the 4.
But now in perturbation
theory this
is the rate for going
from dressed state 1 to 2.
And this is the rate to
go the other way around.
So what is our dressed
state potential?
Well, the dressed
state potential
is simply the EC
stock shift, which
is opposite for the ground
and for the excited state.
And the EC stock shift
in perturbation theory
is nothing else than matrix
elements squared over detuning.
So this is mu naught.
This is the potential of the
standing wave experienced
by the atom.
Now we want to do
Sisyphus cooling.
What is the cooling rate
in Sisyphus cooling?
Well, remember,
Sisyphus cooling we
assume that the
atom is fast enough
to go over several
hills and valleys.
The cooling rate is determined
by the rate at which the atoms
switch dressed levels
times mu naught.
And I can scroll back, but mu
naught was the EC stock effect,
and gamma one, two was this
expression we had before.
So therefore, in
the simple picture,
while everything
is perturbative,
we have a nice expression
for the cooling rate.
Well, now let's get something
non-trivial out of it.
What is the friction
coefficient?
Well, in many
situations I've plotted
for you, the force
versus velocity.
Now I want to plot for you the
cooling rate versus velocity.
That means its force
times velocity.
And as we just discussed, when
the velocity is sufficiently
fast that the atom can go
over several hills and valleys
in a spontaneous
lifetime, the cooling rate
will saturate
because it is limited
by the rate at which
the atom switches
between dressed levels.
But now the question
is, if we want
to understand what
happens at low velocities,
how should we connect the two?
Well, you can say we know,
for analytical reasons,
that the force versus
velocity has to be linear.
So the cooling rate, which
is another power of velocity,
should be quadratic.
And since I neglect all
factors on the order of unity,
this is now the force is
friction coefficient times V.
So therefore, what
I do in red here
is a parabolic
approximation, which
is alpha the cooling
rate times V squared.
And now, if I want to
know what is alpha,
I just sort of
connect this parabola
with the saturated
value, which I know.
And I know the transition
happens at the velocity when
the atom moves further
than one wavelength in one
spontaneous emission time.
So therefore, based on
this very physical picture,
and on the inside how low
velocities and high velocities
connect together, I can actually
obtain the friction coefficient
in this blue detuned standing
wave by taking the cooling rate
and dividing it by the velocity
at which the atom moves
one wavelength per
spontaneous emission time.
And if I do that, I
obtain this result,
which I have already
quoted earlier to you
from the paper of
Cohen-Tonnoudji and Jean
Dalibard.
It looks fairly non-trivial with
power to the 6, power to the 5.
But this is now the simple
perturbative results
for the friction coefficient.
Now we have the
friction coefficient.
Let's take it further.
I want to give you, in
this perturbative limit,
I want to give you the
momentum diffusion coefficient.
And then we will find in
the perturbative limit what
is the lowest temperature
to which we can cool.
So pretty much
I'll do everything
as we've done before, but I use
the simple perturbative limit.
So again, in order to calculate
the diffusion coefficient--
the momentum diffusion
coefficient-- and the heating
we need the fluctuations
of the force.
And now, just remember, we
are in the perturbative limit.
The atom is mainly
in the ground state,
which is the upper
dressed level.
It has only a little
excited stated mixture,
so it will mainly
stay in this state.
But then with this excited
stated mixture and this,
power of the Rabi frequency,
it makes the transition
to the other dressed state.
But the other dressed state
is almost 100% excited state.
So it will leave the
other dressed state
almost immediately.
So this could be a Quantum
Monte Carlo wave function result
that the atom
experiences the force
in the upper dressed level.
Then it goes to the lower
dressed level, which is mainly
the excited state, just
4 times 1 over gamma.
And then it returns.
So the picture now is that the
atom for almost all the time
experiences the steady
state force, which
is the blue dashed line.
And there are only, when it
goes to the other dressed state,
these small spikes where
the force has changed sign.
And if you now calculate the
fluctuations of the force--
the integral of f square--
once we calculate the square
the small deviations
from the average force
does not contribute.
What contributes are the spikes.
So all I do is now I take the
4 square in one of the spikes.
And the force is nothing else
than the derivat-- remember
we have a standing
wave a mu naught.
The derivative of the
standing wave is the force.
But if you have a
sinusoid lattice
the force is K times the
amplitude of the lattice.
I square it, so this
is the spike squared.
Then I have to multiply
with the time 1
over gamma, over which
the force stays the same.
So this is, you can see, the
correlation time of the force.
But then I have
to multiply, also,
when I do an average over
many, sort of, you can see,
trajectories, I have to
average over the probability
that-- I have to multiply
with the probability
that the atom is in
the dressed state
1 and not in the
dressed state 2.
It may take you a
few minutes just
to think about
the combinatorics.
But in the end all I do
is I take the 4 square,
I multiply with correlation time
when the atom is in state 2,
and get the probability
that the atom is in state 2.
And when the atom is in
state 1, in my ensemble,
it doesn't contribute at
all, because in state 1
you're so close to
the average force
that it doesn't contribute
with the fluctuation.
Anyway, it's simple but subtle.
But it's a one-liner.
And now based on
this perturbative
picture we have perturbatively
exact an expression
for the heating rate.
But now it's
interesting, the rate
gamma one, two, the rate to
switch between dressed energy
levels always also appears in
the expression for the friction
coefficient.
So therefore, if
you're now asking
what is the ultimate temperature
to which we can cool the atom?
It is the ratio of this
analytic result for the heating
coefficient divided
by the analytic result
for the friction coefficient.
Pretty much everything
cancels out, and what remains
is mu naught.
And this is a remarkable result.
It's highly non-trivial, and I
really enjoyed showing to you
how simply it can be
derived by-- it's really
just perturbation theory.
But you have to put in the right
concepts from the dressed atom
picture.
So what we learn
is the following.
If you have a
standing wave, and we
cool with a stimulated
force, the lowest temperature
is-- with a prefactor,
which I haven't calculated--
the amplitude of
the standing wave.
And that means that it is
impossible to ever localize
atoms within a standing wave.
Laser cooling cannot be used
to create atoms in an optical
lattice.
The temperature of
the atoms is always
comparable to the
depths of the lattice.
So therefore the
atoms will never
be localized in one
well of the lattice.
And this is generally valid.
The assumption we
have made here is
that we have a two level atom.
A lot of you work with
atoms to optical lattices.
And you often use evaporative
cooling, take a Bose Einstein
condensate, which is pretty much
a [INAUDIBLE] temperature put
it in optical lattice.
But before '95, people studied
laser cooling and atoms
in optical lattices.
And this was only
possible because atoms
can be cooled to
lower temperatures
than we have derived here
because they are not two level
atoms.
So laser cooling
in a standing wave,
localization of atoms in a
standing wave by laser cooling,
is only possibly by physics
beyond what we have discussed.
Colin?
AUDIENCE: If you use something
like Raman's sideband cooling,
you could-- like, yeah,
you'd kind of need
three levels for that, but
you eliminated the third.
Really, it's just that
it's two levels, right?
PROFESSOR: If you do
Raman's sideband cooling,
he posted-- I think,
in the next 10 minutes,
I cover what you want to see.
Because now it involves
two ground states.
And I want to show you, if
you have two ground states,
to Hyper fine-- Raman's
sideband cooling-- if you have
two different ground
states there is no physics.
And I briefly want
to touch upon that.
We'll just kind of
fill in one thing here,
and it is, well, if
you take everything
I've told you seriously,
you would say OK, too bad.
We cannot localize atoms
in an optical lattice
because the temperature
is always comparable
to the amplitude of the lattice.
But by making the lattice
smaller and smaller and smaller
I can reach lower and
lower temperatures.
Well, yes, the some
extent that's possible.
But what we have done here
is we've done approximations.
We've only focused on
the stimulated force.
We have not looked
at the recoil which
comes in spontaneous emission.
And therefore, the moment we
would make the optical lattice
smaller than gamma then
we have to include heating
by the spontaneous light force.
And the result will be that
blue molasses cannot reach lower
temperatures than
red detuned molasses.
And for red detuned
molasses we have already
discussed the famous Doppler
limit, which is gamma over 2.
So that's what I
wanted to present
to you with the
stimulated force.
First, a more general
discussion using the real
dressed atom picture.
But now in the end, to fly
over using sort of the baby
dressed atom picture, which
is simple perturbation theory.
OK, so we've done the hard work.
Now we want to have some
fun discussing the physics.
And I'm realizing I've only
five, six, seven minutes left.
I want to discuss three points.
One is I want to give you all
the different pictures to find
the potential of a dipole
trap, because we've
encountered several.
The second thing is I want
to have a discussion with you
if the stimulated force is due
to electric or magnetic forces.
And eventually, and we'll
be running out of time,
I have to do that on
Wednesday to discuss
the question of
energy conservation.
If you cool the atoms
where does the energy go?
So if you use the
stimulated force,
it gives rise to
dipole potential.
And using the Optical Bloch
Equations or the dressed atom
picture, we found
this expression
for the dipole potential.
And there are at least four ways
how we could have derived it.
One is the Optical Bloch
Equations, we did that.
The dressed atom picture,
we did that today.
Another picture is very
straightforward and simple.
It just says that
the potential is
the electric
potential of a dipole.
And then all you have to know
is from the EC polarizability,
if you drive an atom
with a laser field
below resonance--
I mean that's just
harmonic oscillator--
below resonance
the harmonic oscillator is
in phase with the force.
Above resonance, if you drive
a harmonic oscillator fast,
the response of the harmonic
oscillator is in opposite,
it's out of phase.
So therefore, if your
potential is minus the E,
you are in phase-- it is a
negative attractive potential.
If the harmonic oscillator
is driven above resonance
there is another
minus sign, you get
plus the E, which becomes
a repulsive potential.
So it's, look and
say, just the physics
of a harmonic oscillator.
There's one thing I like,
which is sometimes not
taught in an atomic
physics course
because it is the force on a
macroscopic dielectric object.
So let's assume we
have an atom-- no, we
don't have an atom.
We have something
which is bigger.
Let's assume a tiny
polystyrenes sphere.
You can assume a
small sphere of glass.
What happens if I
shine a laser beam
on a small sphere of glass?
Well, let me assume that
the laser beam is-- well,
if the laser beam hits
this sphere right on,
it's symmetric,
there is no force.
So what we want to do is we
want to have a laser beam, shown
here by this arrow,
which has a maximum here
so the profile is like this.
And we want to discuss
whether this sphere is sucked
into the laser beam, this
would be an attractive force,
or whether this
sphere is repelled.
And all we want
to use is optics,
the optics of refraction.
When we have a laser beam
which is weak, medium, strong,
strong here, and
for red detuning
we have an index of refraction
which is larger than 1.
So the sphere acts like a lens.
So that leaves those
photons up and in,
and those photons up and in.
And when a photon is bent in,
the momentum of the photon
has changed.
And the momentum, of course,
the opposite momentum transfer,
is imparted to the sphere.
So in this case, we
have sort of-- we
have more photons in this
part of the laser beam, which
are bent up, than
photons are bent down.
And this means the net
force is that the sphere is
sucked into the laser beam.
And if you go for
blue detuned light,
where the index of
refraction is smaller than 1,
it is the opposite.
So the picture which
we have discussed here
was for atoms form
microscopic objects.
But you have, actually,
similar physics
of a stimulated force for
mesoscopic and macroscopic
objects.
And then what matters whether
you trap or anti-trap,
is whether the index of
refraction is larger than 1
or smaller than one.
And you know, two level
system for blue detuned light
has an index of refraction
which is smaller than 1.
And for red detuned
light our atomic clouds
have an index of refraction
which is larger than 1.
But this picture that you
can use the same set up,
the same focus beam
and a similar dipole
force to trap larger
objects is actually
exploited in a different
field of physics,
in biology, in the form
of optical tweezers.
When actually in
the early '80s, when
Steve Chu came to Bell Labs
and had discussions with Art
Ashkin, they actually discussed
optical trapping, both of atoms
and both of biological objects,
little microspheres, or cells.
And it's sort of remarkable
that both approaches
were realized within
the same year.
So atoms were trapped in '86.
And macroscopic objects
were manipulated,
I think it's exactly
the same year.
And as you know,
the optical tweezers
is now an important technology
in biology and biophysics.
For instance, you can
focus a laser beam
and manipulate objects
within a living cell.
So I think I should stop here,
but maybe take your questions.
Then let me conclude
with an outlook.
We have this week and next week,
and then the semester is over.
So this week we have
one class on Wednesday.
I want to finish this
discussion and teach
about magnetic trapping
and evaporative cooling.
And the last week, because
of a makeup class on Friday,
we have three more classes,
Monday, Wednesday, Friday.
By the way, I just learned
that the Friday class
is in these room.
And on Monday,
Wednesday, Friday we
talk about, well,
it's really featured
pick about Bose gasses, lecture
one, Fermi gasses, lecture two.
And the third lecture is
about quantum logic with ions.
OK, see you Wednesday.